i i remember talking
you know when me and head were doing
nights together
i know there was a bunch of labels that
are trying to get at you yeah some
people dropped the ball
uh others didn't you ended up with roc
nation
um what made like roc nation be like
like what what's the fit like with like
with roc nation because obviously
you know parika was over there um
and they're not they don't have the
craziest history when it comes to like
breaking new artists i mean also
specifically la artists
yeah i mean
with uh what you're saying that like
they don't have the best history you
mean
i'm not saying they have a bad history
no no i can't you know what you're
saying like
i mean obviously they had j cole and
they you know there's like artists that
they have everybody's from l.a they
right i mean it's just like they wanted
me
too shout out to the homie earl tools
jimmy like no shout out earl that's my
that's my guy
but it's like talking like everything i
relate everything to women because
that's
my the most experiences i've ever had in
life right now you feel me
you can't keep talking to a girl that
don't want you nothing's gonna happen
like it's cool like she want to go out
you feel me you could take her on a date
and stuff like that but that don't mean
she like you
right you know if anything you lose it
yeah you you losing if anything you cut
her off and ignore her
she's gaining that yeah you feel me so
i mean i just always look at like like
even with the recruiting process like
with football and [ __ ] like that like
you got to go where you're most
comfortable and just with roc nation you
feel me i felt like they wanted me just
as much as i wanted them right you feel
me not to say that i really wanted
them like oh i just want to be signing
roc nation like that's the only people
i'm assigned to not saying that right
it's saying that i knew where i wanted
to be
in my life you know and i knew with this
music [ __ ]
what what's the next step and what i
need like everybody don't need to sign
to a label
this is facts man it worked for some
people you feel me but
where i was that was the next step
mm-hmm like you found me i was accepted
it was
i was accepting that this was this is
the next step
also like opportunities like you know
having scoring like be part of nba games
and
yeah i mean like that but nobody ever
like i was already sorry before that
happened
so like i didn't know that was gonna
happen but you feel me i'm gonna take a
chance on the people that's willing to
take a chance on me
that's real they genuinely gave a [ __ ]
about everything that was going on and
then i
they genuinely give a [ __ ] about
everything that i have going on
and i know that also comes with uh
per with uh your progression and uh what
you're doing
like you know i also know that if i
start [ __ ] up that or if you start
making some [ __ ] yeah you find me
them call's not gonna get answered no
more no you gotta you gotta you have to
do your part as much as they gotta do
their part
sometimes people don't realize that when
they sign with labels they're like
people don't fam you still got to do
your
part at the end of the day absolutely
absolutely this [ __ ] is about you
at the end of the day and like
respectively like
at the end of the day kaelin you're a
product
to the marketplace your music
yeah and just because like i'm
emotionally tired and connected to all
of this [ __ ] it doesn't matter
yeah it's at the end of the day
consumers have to want to consume your
music
there this is it's a business it's not a
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's not saying that
this is a clubhouse your life changed
like this [ __ ] is working that's why
it's like you got to do your part as
much as they got to do their part like a
lot of people are seeing unhappy with
their labels i'm like yeah but you're
also
what are you doing what are you doing
are you unhappy with your label well you
don't know if you're um if you're like
it's two sides to everything
100 you don't know if you're labeled
unhappy with you mm-hmm you know i mean
so it's just like
you got to do what you got to do so you
can do what you want to do
you know